[Music]
kourtney kardashian is the
ultimate multitasker having fun with her
gal pal addison ray
and promoting her boyfriend travis
barker's new music
all at the same time i love it the 42
year old reality star took to tick tock
over the weekend to lip sync to jaden's
new song
think about me which features travis on
the drums
[Music]
in the video court and addison rock
matching khaki colored sweatshirts
and belt out that chorus into some hair
brushes
[Music]
court captioned the clip quote it's the
spins for me
as for travis he seemingly gave his
stamp of approval
reposting the clip to his insta story
i'm just like
living life and whatever happens happens
in addition to their epic lip sync the
gal pals also recreated a dance for
addison's account
with this side-by-side reenactment
someone call my bestie think i found my
that i'm smoking besties i'll be hot so
next week know i had to let her go
cause she can't harass me turns out
addison
isn't just a fan of travis's music she's
also
a big fan of his relationship with court
last month the 20 year old tick tock
star
gushed to e.t over the couple's romance
i'm obsessed i'm obsessed i love
courtney and i love travis they're
amazing people and i wish them the best
they're so cute
earlier this year addison made an
appearance on the 20th and final season
of keeping up with the kardashians
what the [ __ ] do you do to courtney to
make her so happy honestly
at the beginning we were like wait are
they
i'm still thinking that hooking up
if it was like that kind of relationship
as for travis
he hasn't made an appearance this season
but a source tells e.t
fans can expect to see the musician on
court's new hulu show with the rest of
her famous fam
quote travis is expected to make an
appearance on the kardashians hulu show
his kids may appear as well but not as
much as he will be featured
the source adds that the two are doing
great and travis just wants to keep her
happy
i love you as for travis's relationship
with court's ex
scott disick the source says the two
have never bonded
even when courtney and travis were just
friends adding quote travis and scott
are very different i mean i think you
just gotta
figure out really what's important to
you at the end of the day and scott
well things appear to be getting hot and
heavy with him and his girlfriend
19 year old amelia gray hamlin on sunday
he shared
this sultry shot of the model wearing
lingerie on his
insta story amelia later shared snaps on
her page from the same location
rocking the same sexy look you just want
to be happy
you want to be content you want to be
comfortable last month amelia gifted her
man with a harley-davidson motorcycle
for his birthday
and at the time a source told et that
scott is amelia's first serious
boyfriend
quote amelia and scott are doing well
amelia is mature for her age and scott
and her get along great
and things are easy